dissidia déjà j'attends bas j'allais au
tour abattu c'est quoi tu vas bien
écouter les anecdotes on a deux on a
trois anecdotes de mariage c'est obligé
c'est bizarre
excuse moi tu bosses encore aulas tu
bosses sauts au club house est là mais
ils sont partis sur le parcours les
centres ou quatre voire toi va super
content que tu sois là je passais un
contenu un peu c'est quoi ta vie d'un
gars comme toi quoi voilà qu'est ce que
tu fais c'est quoi tes projets c'est
quoi ta trousse toi je me lève je me
lève puis la patate quand j'ai la niaque
dès le matin qu'on n'arrive pas à quoi
tu as toujours la patate hausse quoi ça
boume sa surboum toujours quoi le projet
sur equidia on est là mais sont là quoi
tu continue toujours t/t aventure
radiophonique à sur virgin radio le
matin
ouais ouais je suis un peu le match
ouais je passe une tête le matin m merci
en avoir tant tardé mais pas sa loquace
et mmhg le passé qui viennent ça alors
c'est toi camille combal à la nouvelle
star du paf là alors tu vois que tu as
pas perdu la main des comptes tu content
que tu sois là nous fait une petite
émission écoute si tu veux passer une
tête c'est quoi vous lassez cache pas
mon poste des huit reconnais pas
merahi pause je connais pas le délire ça
me dit rien qui arrive quelque chose pas
tu aimes pas légal ou jabri d'une gueule
particulièrement que j'aime pas ça mais
bon même et chasser quelqu'un dont je
vais me séparer mi septembre
ah non non alors quand on mange sur le
plateau puis toi tu es un coup laisse
mon show
[Applaudissements]
allez camille comment